Have you ever heard about the energy enhancement system?
Yes, I think we have a couple of patients that have gone through the EES system.
It's supposed to generate scalar ways for cell regeneration and immune function.
To my understanding, it's a type of low frequency PEMF.
Low Gauss PEMF. I looked it up once.
I did not look it up prior to this call.
So I'm just reading this question right now.
Balancing the hemispheres of the brain.
Understand there's all sorts of claims that.
Companies can make with electrical frequency like this.
I'd be very careful about that.
You're balancing the hemispheres of the brain.
So in functional neurology circles, there is a phenomenon called right brain dominance or left brain dominance.
You're typically talking about the prefrontal cortex part of the brain.
So you have the cortex, the outer part of the brain, and then you have the pre the frontal cortex.
So if you put your hand on your forehead, that's your frontal cortex.
Different parts of the frontal cortex.
You have the three motor cortex and then the motor cortex.
So the frontal cortex consists largely of the motor cortex, which basically tells your different muscles what to do.
So if you want to raise your right hand, your left motor cortex fires.
It's a signal crossing that is at the corner crop and going to the right hand to coordinate that movement.
There is a phenomenon called brain imbalance.
You can have right brain dominance or left brain dominance.
And you can check that with a neurological proper functional neurological exam.
That right or left brain dominance is is corrected through specific exercises of the opposite to exercise the opposite side of the brain that's last dominant.
And there's the entire there's a entire educational library around that.
But when that when those studies were done in the 90s and early 2000s about that, there's a bunch of different companies that came up and talked about, you know, using our device will balance the hemispheres of the brain and blown.
There's a whole bunch of different things to balance the hemispheres of the brain.
Typically they're really, really low gossip EMF things. They are some of them are poorly made.
Machines that are supposed to help with neurofeedback.
But to do proper neurofeedback, you need a neurofeedback system that is going to touch on multiple points on the brain to affect the different brain waves.
So the different brain waves have to do with with how the brain is function at a low at a pulse rate.
True right when Michael true right he came up with with a kind of poorly created.
I thought I wasn't a fan of his kind of a cheap neurofeedback device.
I don't mean that negatively, but I studied neurofeedback extensively.
Many of you know that actually had we old the neurofeedback clinic for whatever of years we did neurofeedback in our office.
So a doctor Kelly Halterman was with me or I were both certified in neurofeedback and functional neurology.
We saw great success with it, but we had the brain master system which at that time was the best on the market.
There are several other really good ones now.
Brain master is still considered the top of the line.
And Mike system did, you know, though, you know, he tried to create something that would stimulate different waves.
It's just you have to have these points of the skull that are that you're stimulating.
You have to be able to control a computer screen with your brain waves in order for it to be true neurofeedback.
So unfortunately those machines you have to have some training to use those machines and they cost several thousand dollars to do a home machine like that.
There's several neurofeedback companies that have come out with different type of things and they use all sorts of term terminology to make it sound like it's great.
And not to say that there can't be some success with those things, but I wouldn't necessarily use the right machine to try to retrain my brain.
Even though there can be, it makes more sense to run your right on alpha frequencies or data frequencies to help call your brain down that it does some of those devices.
I'm talking this specific device and their specific systems, I, you know, looked at it, I don't know, six, eight months ago and somebody else asked a question about this.
But yeah, in order to really make brain wave changes, you need to do multiple, multiple sessions of true neurofeedback equipment.
They, instead of investing in something like this, start running your right on those anxiety programs, those anxiety programs and in the, I think there's actually a folder with brain training programs that stimulate data waves and alpha waves because most the time a person's issue is there in a high beta wave, that's why they have anxiety, that's why they have a difficult time call me their parasympathetics.
Because we're stimulated by beta waves all the time so a beta wave is anything over 30 beta wave and your brain is about 26 to 32 hurt and you're stimulated just sitting here watching your computer screen right now you're stimulated at 60 hertz every time you look at any screen a screen.
I mean, computer screen and television screen your phone screen all vibrate at 60 hertz so you're basically stimulated your brain at 60 hertz that's why you shouldn't, you know, that's why you should live at screen time with young kids because you're basically neurofeedback training their brain at 60 hertz no wonder they're hyper active.
You know, the first, you know, the difficulty that we had doing neurofeedback is people wouldn't these people didn't have cancer, okay, so they wouldn't necessarily be as serious about their treatment program and quite honestly I used to see a lot of functional neurology patients, we used to see a lot of ADD ADHD kids, a lot of neurofeedback work.
And I got out of it to be honest because I was I was so frustrated that people wouldn't do what I told you do you know you got to go off gluten you got to go off dairy test their food issues and they have these inflammatory foods that they're eating that are firing inflammation to their brain and you got to go off the screen time you got to limit screen time get your kids outside playing don't let them watch TV don't let them have a phone.
Why does your 10 year old have a freaking cell phone and you know parents what did listen they wouldn't follow it they didn't have enough discipline in their home to teach their kids.
The kids would run the home or they were from a divorced family and i'm not feeding my kid any of this stuff but every time he goes home for his dad his dad says oh there's a nonsense and he just stuff some full of garbage.
And he dies and chemical so it just got so frustrated it's like I'm not doing this anymore I literally I just we just closed our neurofeedback center it's very profitable I just but I just like it was just so frustrating that's what I just said I'm only working with cancer patients because at least they're they're you know see their condition as serious enough that they'll make the changes that they need to make.
Of course we with our courses we see other people to know but.
This is where a lot of people have asked me do you take every patient you know and the answer is no if I don't feel like they're good fit for us if I don't feel like they're going to listen to me nothing I know everything but you know but if you won't if you're going to run a lab and not do.
What you know it's just mind boggling to me you know we've had patients that we run like a micotoxin lab cancer patient runs a micotoxin lab super high in micotoxins and their husband says oh I don't believe in micotoxins so we're not going to do it okay well here's a here's a Google scholar search for a hundred and six thousand articles that are peer reviewed articles published on micotoxins in cancer.
Still you don't believe it okay well I'm done so it's it's just very frustrating when what do you deal with that back to this question is this system a good system I don't know baby you can check it out and I want to knock it but you know if it helps you and then great but what are you trying to do with it are you trying to.
To balance the hemispheres of your brain you're probably better off going to a good functional neurologist who can do some neural functional neurology testing on you and do give you some specific exercises probably just better off just doing all the parasympathetic exercises and the best and symbolic suppressing exercises that we have right on your member site.
And right on our website that's going to take a half hour day to do that you probably have better results with that.